I'm yukihira Selma truth be told I
didn't expect to be admitted in this
Academy but I don't plan on losing to
some bunch that has never stood in front
of clients I'll use all of you as
stepping stones now that I'm here I'll
take the top hello and welcome to
shokugeki 101 the series that breaks
down everyone and everything in the
shokugeki no souma world today we are
going to be taking a look at the
energetic heir to the yukihira diner and
the current first seat of the elite n
yukihira selma yukihira soma is a
student of Totsuka Academy with spiky
dark red hair and yellow eyes his goals
are to beat his father Yuki Gaeta Joey
cheeto in a cooking duel as well as have
knockety Erina admit that his cooking is
delicious he is a hyper energetic
optimist who gives everything he can
offer to the world of cooking and is
always in search of a new challenge
although he can also be described as
incredibly reckless and will often
purposely put himself in situations that
have the potential to end his cooking
career sama began his culinary journey
at the mere age of three working in his
father's restaurant the yukihira diner
where he became motivated to one day
become a better chef than his father
with that said soma respects his father
as his mentor friend and rival in terms
of being a mentor specifically Joey
cheeto invented the yukihira style of
cooking the yukihira style is a very
experimental style of cooking which
involves combining a variety of
different cooking disciplines from all
over the world and is practiced
exclusively by joey cheeto and soma the
main strength of this style is the
constant evolution as so enjoy to know
often experiment with wildly different
ingredients and different preparation
techniques however this does often
result in horrible food combinations
like soma sphered grilled squid
tentacles to rest in peanut butter but
more often than not it leads both soma
angelito to a whole universe of
fantastic flavors as a result the
yukihira style is very hard to master
because of the sheer amount of research
and experimentation that is required to
engage in it starting from soma six year
of primary school he engaged
numerous cooking duels with his dad
determined to beat him this resulted in
489 straight losses and no wins for soma
until his father mysteriously decided to
close the yukihira diner for three years
and recommended to selma that he attend
Toth Sookie Culinary Academy an despite
a bit of a rocky start with the entrance
exam soma immediately excelled in the
Academy thanks to the incredibly
adaptable you can hear a style of
cooking a great example of this would be
during the breakfast challenge at the
training camp where soma exceptionally
quickly learned the alive cooking
technique in just one day to avoid
getting expelled Salma is also able to
adapt to his opponents specialties and
often tries to beat them with his own
unique spin on their methods challenging
meto Iike me
hi Emma Ikeda Curitiba Rio and coveted
Inori all with their respective
specialties against Mito soma combined
shalyapin steak with the donburi concept
and attempted to defeat a commis
high-class meat with ingredients he
found in a supermarket most importantly
though his shalyapin steak Don
encapsulated the donburi mantra Don's
are completed in one Bowl which led to
his complete victory over her against
hyoma and Kido Kaiba so I made an odious
style Pacific sour eat Akiko me Gohan it
should be noted that the Pacific salary
is a fish with an intensive smell which
gave an advantage to both the sensory
master hiya MA Ikeda as well as the
seafood extraordinaire Kudo Kiba Rio
against them soma used rice bran and soy
milk to forge his own Pacific salary
flavor and although he ultimately lost
the 43rd annual toad tsuki autumn
election finals he proved himself
capable of going toe-to-toe with his
opponents even at a disadvantage when
faced with a daunting challenge of
outselling the entire Chinese research
society soman decided to fight Cugat era
Nori's signature spicy Mapo tofu dish
with his own hand
made who Joe Bing buns cooked inside a
clay oven Selma even managed to surpass
Cougars overall sales on the fourth day
of the Moon banquet festival serving up
his own style of Chinese cuisine
time-fuse Mapo curry noodles
however the skill that ultimately
clinched Selma's victory was actually
his prowess at adapting his menu and
service to meet his customers needs
skills that he first honed while working
in the yukihira diner but what about
stomas own specialty to put it broadly
some a specialty upon entering Totsuka
would have been Japanese cuisine but one
of his greatest influence after
enrolling in the Academy would have come
from the world of French cuisine
during his stay shear summer was
personally trained by XI knowmia cachito
a master of French cooking in a former
first seat of the Totsuka elite ten
although it should be said that the two
first met as enemies during the hellish
Totsuka friendship and rapport training
camp she Tamiya fired silmas close
friend Toto kromega me the pair then
challenged to know me into a cooking
duel during which soma showed off his
expertise as a sous chef while assisting
Todoke guru the two ultimately reignited
shinomiya Zam bhishan's to reach new
heights in the culinary world as time
went on she knowmia began to act as a
mentor for soma with the young cook even
going as far as calling shinomiya
his master although most of sohmas pure
inspiration for cooking comes directly
from his friends many of whom live with
him in the PolarStar dormitory in
particular solo draw strength from taro
kromega me who is arguably sohma's
closest and most loyal ally and the to
have a shared appreciation for each
other's abilities and while someone has
made many other friends at Toad Sookie
he also has made quite a fair few
enemies as well a lot of this stemmed
from his very first date when soma
declared he would stand at the top of
toad tsuki by the end of their high
school life this caused many students to
boo him off stage and made him a target
for essentially every other student in
the school a few examples of these
students are Akuma Mito aldini Takumi
na ki Alice kudo-kai barrio and hyoma
Ikeda all who have appeared as
antagonists before ultimately succumbing
to the yukihira charm
these days they are much more friendly
rivals than enemies however the biggest
rival Silla made at the opening ceremony
was without a doubt knockety arena
airing of views herself is superior to
all of her classmates and especially
looks down on selma because of his
significantly less prestigious
background but even Erina would
eventually be won over by selma when the
two were forced to work together in
order to combat naka Diaz amis reign of
terror over Tatsu key
eventually securing victory against his
forces in the original NZ cuisine
after which silla became the first seat
of the new elite 10 and Erina became the
new headmaster of Toad ski Academy still
chasing after the best soma travels the
endless wasteland of the cooking world
challenging stronger opponents every day
against the newest obstacle of
underworld chefs lake we zinnia noir we
can only expect so much growth even
stronger than ever before in order to
complete the quest of one day beating
his father some more fun facts about
yukihira soma
sohmas name uses the kanji for creation
and true reflecting his boundless
creativity while yuki heeda can be
translated to blessing of the ordinary
reflecting his humble background soma is
the only student to ever be appointed
first seat of ely 10 while still in his
first year surpassing even not easá me
who became third seat in his first year
and finally a truly useless fact when he
has a rare moment that doesn't involve
cooking soma very much enjoys doing
laundry and that pretty much does it for
you Keita soma if you enjoyed this video
and the content this channel produces in
general then please do feel free to like
comment or subscribe and if you'd like
to join in on the fun at anytime then
feel free to head over to our discord
server where a wide array of shenanigan
retakes place on a daily basis and
finally please do comment with who what
or where you'd like to see featured on
the next show kageki 101